la Organización de Estados Americanos
acaba de aprobar una resolución de
respaldo a la paz total en Colombia Este
ha sido el primer proyecto acorrado en
mayoría por los países integrantes
previamente el canciller colombiano
Álvaro Leyva formuló un llamado a los
gobiernos de la región para que la paz
Total no sea entendida como negociación
política sino como negociación de
Justicia para que haya un acogimiento a
fin de consolidar la paz total Leyva
agradecido el respaldo de la
organización de los Estados Americanos y
afirmó que la búsqueda de paz es un
sueño que ve transmitirse a la oea por
otro lado los cancilleres que asisten a
esta que en guajésima Asamblea que se
realiza en Perú también aprobaron una
declaración de solidaridad con la
República de Argentina ante el intento
de asesinato que sufrió la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández en
septiembre pasado la delegación
Argentina tras agradecer la declaración
afirmó que la intención de magnicidio
contra Fernández fue un hecho que no
tenía precedentes en la historia de la
nación Sudamericana y en otro capítulo
de esta asamblea general la oea rechazó
debatir un proyecto presentado por
Venezuela para revocar la representación
de Juan guaidó ante el organismo